so now our page has the correct layout
but we need to make sure that our page
looks good on all size screens not just
this big one so let's go ahead and
resize it you can see it gets smaller
and as we get closer and closer to the
mobile size we can see that this image
is being pushed off the side of the
screen I'll go ahead and make it big
again it's important to make sure that
our websites look good on mobile too so
we need to make some changes using
bootstrap look through the bootstrap
documentation to answer this question
which class should you apply to images
to make them resize automatically type
your answer in here